et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
jean françois copé bon jour où j'ai
aussi beaucoup d'être avec nous vers
l'est républicain de mon conseiller
spécial de valérie pécresse vous êtes
avec nous pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représentée par
stéphane bern et de ouest france bonjour
stéphane bonjour bonjour et on parle
évidemment du cred pour commencer jean
françois copé des troupes aéroportées
qui ont donc été débarqué cette nuit sur
kharkiv la deuxième ville d'ukraine ya
ces colonnes de blanc dès qu'ils sont à
l'antillaise toujours mal de 60km de
blindés druss de blindés russes est-ce
qu'on peut encore arrêté de la dernière
côte sion à bâle eux on est au coeur
d'une crise d'une gravité exceptionnelle
donc je ne suis pas évidemment en
situation de répondre par oui ou par non
à cette question la réalité c'est qu'il
faut toujours quand on a des crises et
contre les responsables politiques et
qu'on est face à une crise de cette
importance de cette violence c'est la
pire puisque c'est celle de la guerre en
permanence
équilibrer sa réflexion stratégique
entre la gestion immédiate de la
tragédie et c'en est bien une et la
prise de recul nécessaire pour éviter
des décisions impulsives et c'est toute
la subtilité et en même temps la
détermination de l'union européenne et
la france dans cette période de crise
qui est qui est en jeu aujourd'hui alors
très concrètement quelle est notre sujet
notre sujet c'est de bien comprendre
qu'on a d'un côté un dictateur qui en
réalité totalement isolé depuis des
années dans dans sa manière de voir les
choses et qui dès le début de mon point
de vue commis une double erreur la
première c'est avoir totalement
sous-estimé ce qu'est l'ukraine
d'aujourd'hui qui n'a plus rien à voir
avec celle des deux ça pour plein de
raisons et puis deuxièmement encore qu
on pourrait en discuter d'ailleurs et
puis deuxièmement une sous-estimer une
union européenne dont la réaction a été
extrêmement coordonnées
donc c'est vrai que dans ce contexte là
bas chaque jour et dur parce
qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien un poutine
qui est absolument
déterminé avec une violence inacceptable
et insupportable à broyer d'ukraine et
et à le faire avec des armes d'une
violence extrême et puis de l'autre une
réaction des occidentaux et en
particulier des européens qui est quand
même très très méthodique très déterminé
et c'est ce combat là que l'on doit
absolument mener ça ça vous a surpris le
fait que cette réaction européenne soit
aussi coordonnée qui est une vraie unité
sur le sujet je n'aime pas le mot
surpris parce que il ya un côté là on
n'était pas au courant là dessus de
l'union européenne jusqu'à jusqu'à
aujourd'hui toi on n'a jamais jamais été
confronté à quelque chose d'aussi médias
d'aussi brutale ça montre une chose en
tout cas et c'est que cette union
européenne et ses dirigeants surtout
sont vraiment imprégnés d'histoire est
en réalité c'est ça le coeur de la
noblesse de l'ape du métier politique
c'est d'avoir toujours en tête quand on
est un dirigeant politique d'où on vient
or on voit bien que les dirigeants
politiques y compris ceux qui sont comme
c'est mon cas pas aux affaires mais
évidemment il ya les youri terre
d'autres circonstances c'est d'avoir
toujours en tête 1938 munich et
1962 la crise des fusées à cuba et en
réalité ne vous y trompez pas cessé
c'est quelque part trouver un nouveau
chemin en ayant évidemment en tête c'est
de ces deux épisodes très très
importante commande de le prouver ce
nouveau chemin à l'échelle européenne
notamment par le d'une proposition de
médiation via nicolas sarkozy s'est
organisé ça ou 160 là on n'est pas du
tout dans le sujet d'une médiation va
séparer c'est pas le nier
aujourd'hui attendait juste pour bien
bien bien voir de quoi on parle d'abord
premiers éléments l'union européenne ou
liszt a surpris on est un réflexe vital
car là on a compris que c'est l'ensemble
de l'avenir de l'europe qui est en jeu
au delà même de la tragédie ukrainienne
on sait que là on ne peut pas laisser
passer et donc il faut qu'on arrive à
trouver tous les moyens et on va les
trouver au fur et à mesure pour ne pas
laisser passer donc il ya effectivement
une première manche dans laquelle comme
toujours au jeu d'échecs celui qui joue
le premier couac a évidemment qui
surprend mais vous voyez que la réplique
commence à se construire de manière très
méthodique chaque jour qui passe en
force cette réplique sanctions
économiques sanctions financières à bien
la
livraison d'armes et puis j'ajoute quand
même à cela parce qu'il faut toujours
regarder le théâtre géopolitique une
chine qui au début avec une abstention
en gardant tu qui prend un peu de recul
la turquie qui rappelle qu'elle est dans
l'otan et face à cela un bloc européen
extraordinairement solide donc c'est ça
aussi qu'il faut regarder en montrant
qu'un ayant bien en tête que tout ça
malheureusement va durer il ya beaucoup
de choses dans ce que vous venez de dire
d'abord vous dites la médiation
s'appelle suivre et sa meilleure qu est
ce qu il faut continuer à dialoguer
bouyges la dîmière poutine aujourd'hui
mais ce qu'il faut instaurer un rapport
de force mais les deux d'abord bien
gardé cette loi fondamentale de la
politique en tête il n'y a pas de
diplomatie sans rapport de forces est
dans une crise il faut toujours qu'il y
ait un fils diplomatique mais c'est ce
fil diplomatique pour qu'ils soient
crédibles
simple s'appuie sur un rapport de force
deuxième vingt trois raisons de
continuer à appeler bien sûr bien sûr
deuxième élément ce rapport de force
n'existe pas
s'il n'y a pas derrière une politique de
défense
aujourd'hui on le sait tous poutine ne
savait aussi c'est notre maillon faible
heureusement que la france et la grande
bretagne même si le puits dans l'union
européenne ont gardé cette détermination
à tenir et regardez cet événement
absolument majeur qu'a constitué la
décision du chancelier allemand vous
avez évidemment vu son discours au
bundestag d'accroître pour la première
fois depuis 1945 de manière massive le
budget de la défense
milliards
sinon il y aura un avant et un après
quand on fait ce type d'annoncé pas pour
l'heure tiré huit jours après donc ça
veut dire que désormais le débat la
défense européenne met sur la table que
même si naturellement on continuera
d'être dans l'otan personne n'imagine de
renoncer à l'otan mais on a compris
qu'il fallait enfin comprennent notre
destin ça posera d'autres problèmes mais
au moins là dessus on est au clair il
faut impérativement que les pays
européens qui le peuvent rejoignent la
france dans cet effort majeur doit
encore augmenter son budget même si elle
a fait ces dernières années il faut
encore désarmé en tout cas en tout cas
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il faut
réorganiser ce que taylor valérie
pécresse a rappelé réorganiser
absolument notre notre appareil de
défense pour tenir compte des nouvelles
menaces mais ça nous renvoie ça vous que
je vous dise est toujours très important
d'avoir aussi un une réflexion un peu
avec du recul ça nous renvoie quand même
à ce paradoxe incroyable l'europe
traumatisé par l'après guerre qui
construit ce formidable projet qu'est
l'union européenne un projet de paix et
quittant le même temps n'imagine pas que
ce projet de paix doivent être adossés
sur une armée quand on y pense
rétrospectivement bbc fou et ça donne
une idée aussi de ce qu'a été de ce
qu'ont été ses 50 années post caire où
il a fallu construire autre chose le
fait en vrai pardon le fait d'envoyer
des armes aux ukrainiens en fait ça
c'est une nouvelle posture aussi de la
part de l'europe vous avez un jean luc
mélenchon il ya par exemple au débat à
l'assemblée nationale qui disait que
c'était risqué qui est que ça faisait de
nous des potentiellement déco blg ans et
qu'il ya la possibilité de mettre le
doigt jusqu'où au bras dans un an mais
le bras dans un engrenage dangereux bien
sûr oui ça c'est normal que l'extrême
gauche comme d'ailleurs l'extrême droite
tiennent ce discours est là il n'y a pas
de surprise e par définition une
position que l'envoi d'armes c'est une
tuerie dans l'eau ni des listes allait
faire
à la fois pour défendre nos valeurs être
aux côtés du peuple ukrainien qui est
agressée dans des conditions absolument
insupportable et inadmissible et puis
aussi pour nous défendre nous et c'est
là où l'on retrouve mais c'est la grande
tradition de l'extrémisme de l'extrême
gauche mais aussi de l'extrême droite ne
vous y trompez pas zemmour et le pen
pense exactement la même chose
le pen l'a dit hier soir si kobe liger
vue bien sûr mais pourquoi mais tout
simplement parce qu'on retrouve là la
grande tradition l'extrême droite
française vous aviez les mêmes qui
disaient les mêmes choses sur hitler 2
dans les années 30 c'est les mêmes ce
sont des gens qui considèrent que de
toute façon sur ces sujets là eh bien il
ya une fascination pour le dictateur
voilà eh ben c'est pas notre idée des
choses et c'est pour cela il ya encore
pour vous chez marine le pen et chez les
croyants gym quand vous écoutez vous
prenez les verbatim quand zemmour dit
manque un aliment cas vladimir poutine à
la france et c'est la phrase année à 10
et le vladimir poutine que j'ai
rencontrés en 2007 c'est à dire pourquoi
oui on sait sur abbas est sur wii ma
fille parlait déjà d'ukraine il était il
enfermé déjà ses opposants ça faisait
déjà le cam 17 ans qu'il était au
pouvoir dans des conditions que tout le
monde connaît bon qu'il faille pour des
raisons d'intérêt stratégique parler à
d'autres pays avec lesquels on n'est pas
d'accord bah oui sinon il n'y a pas de
diplomatie mais aurait été même la peine
d'aller beaucoup plus loin sa collusion
avec le pouvoir russe est parfaitement
connue donc là ils font un foot
d'ailleurs le pen comme zemmour fait un
virage essaye de faire un virage à 180
degrés ce qui sont quand même un peu mal
à l'aise mais la réalité c'est qu'ils
sont l'un comme l'autre totalement
discrédité pour être président de la
république je je je mets les pieds dans
le plat il faut quand même qu'on voit de
quoi on parle il ya une élection
présidentielle vous imaginez dans deux à
moi à voir à la tête de notre pays des
gens qui explique qu'il faudrait un
putin tête de la france monsieur zemmour
et madame le pen sont mais totalement
discrédité d'abord parce que c'est leur
projet est fondé sur une analyse menée
erreur d'interprétation de du sens de
l'histoire absolument
inadmissible et qui les rend disqualifié
puis deuxièmement parce que là tout de
suite c'est dangereux quand même alors a
contrario quand bruno le maire de nice
de l'économie par le de livrer une
guerre économique et financière totale à
la russie et ensuite rétropédale en
disant que le terme était inapproprié il
était là il est allé il est allé trop
loin à un moment il parle il parle
parler de couper la messagerie boris
belge une arme nucléaire financière en
cette vie il l'a dit il
il est revenu dessus pour moi le sujet
il est clos aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas écoutés par dont il il est
revenu dessus encore une fois vous savez
de la période étant ce qu'elle est je
propose que vraiment on se trompe pas de
combat bon et je ne veux surtout pas
qu'on donne vis-à-vis du pouvoir de
monsieur poutine l'image d'être divisés
sur une stratégie que nous pouvons sur
certaines nuances éthique est d'ailleurs
un avec ce que fait le gouvernement
place mais qui en tout état de cause est
la seule possible c'est à dire celle
d'une fermeté absolue vis-à-vis de
poutine d'une solidarité européenne
totale d'un travail de chaque instant
pour convaincre qu'il faut aller plus
loin dans les sanctions économiques
financières dans l'engagement parce que
c'est en réalité l'avenir de l'europe
qui est en jeu c'est l'avenir de
l'europe qui est en jeu au delà de la
nécessité pour nous tous de nous d'être
solidaire vis-à-vis de l'ukraine est
d'ailleurs en tant que maire de meaux
nous avons nous lançons dès ce matin une
collecte de toutes tous les dons
possibles dans tous les domaines de les
plus essentiels de la vie quotidienne
qui va être acheminé via la mf vers les
ukrainiens et puis bien sûr nous avons
affiché les couleurs de l'ukraine sur
notre bel objectif c'est quand même de
parvenir à une désescalade dans ce
conflit qui est bien sûr m très
inquiétant on voit pas bien les voix qui
sont ici qui s'offre à nous aujourd'hui
non mais c'est le principe des crises de
cette nature vous savez le principe de
ces crises et qu'il ya toujours plein de
scénarios sur la table et on ne doit en
est on évacue et aucun malheureusement
dans ces périodes il faut pas mentir aux
français tout est possible tout est
possible et donc il faut être à la fois
il faut faire preuve de beaucoup de
sang-froid et en même temps savoir que
toutes les options face à un dictateur
qui a conduit une invasion de cette
nature toutes les options sont sur la
table être en permanence c'est pour ça
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure instruits
de l'expérience de l'histoire ne jamais
oublier les erreurs qui ont été commises
par les dirigeants du passé c'est pour
ça que où les erreurs ou les bonnes
décisions c'est pour ça que je citais
munich 1938 face à hitler ou bien
l'épisode des des fusées
le plus bas en 1962 qui montrent
qu'effectivement la gestion de crise
c'est en permanence plusieurs scénarios
sur la table et une très grande solidité
dans le combat qu'on doit mener jeu pour
revenir sur les questions économiques à
des questions qui se posent sur les
liens de certaines entreprises
françaises avec la russie notamment
total notamment angie est ce que pour
vous ces entreprises doivent cesser
leurs activités en russie elles doivent
le faire de toute façon c'est
inéluctable on ne peut pas travailler
avec un pays qui a commis une invasion
qui menace directement le territoire
européen donc cesser de toute façon pas
possible durablement il appartient à ces
dirigeants qui sont des grands
dirigeants c'est vrai d'ailleurs
d'autres grands dirigeants lancent en
particulier à des grands groupes
allemands par exemple mais ce qui est
important surtout c'est de pouvoir le
faire en bon ordre pour éviter de mettre
en péril nos groupes industriels ou
financiers donc c'est ce travail là
auxquels bien sûr il convient de de se
consacrer bien sûr mais à mesure que
l'on est à présent c'est contre les
chaînes rts pique nique ils sont
interdites des maîtres dans l'union
européenne à partir d'aujourd'hui 7 est
une manne mais ce n'est bien sûr mais
bien sûr c'était indispensable moi je
pense que cela fait partie aussi des
messages que l'on adressé il ya
évidemment des décisions dont l'impact
économique est extrêmement important on
n'a pas de financiers exemple elle le
fait d'avoir interrompu les usages des
réseaux swift des réseaux interbancaire
mais mais il ya aussi des red et des
décisions symboliques je pense au
domaine sportif par exemple là on voit
bien que dans ce domaine il fallait
aussi montré qu'on ne pouvait pas
partager des moments sportifs de
convivialité d'émotion avec eux c'est
uniquement symbolique parce qu'on sait
que la diplomation sportif c'est très
bas et des
contrôles continus et ses symboles les
symboles ça aide aussi à convaincre les
opinions publiques les symboles c'est
souvent beaucoup plus fort que certaines
autres décisions dont l'impact concret
et immédiat après on a évidemment un
sujet vous avez tout à fait raison on a
un sujet avec l'opinion russe l'opinion
publique russe parce que tout ce que
l'on comprend c'est qu'évidemment il n'y
a pas du tout de liberté d'information
et qu'on raconte on raconte auris
n'importe quoi comme d'ailleurs hitler
raconter aux allemands n'importe quoi
pendant le pendant les années 30 donc là
il faut qu'on soit très attentifs à
passer les canaux d'information côlon
dont on peut disposer et internet
évidemment peut-être un élément et puis
à contrario que des chaînes qui a
évidemment son copain comblement partiel
comme peut l'être russie à tous day je
vois pas comment ils peuvent émettre en
ce moment mais vous pensez vraiment
qu'un que l'opinion en russie peut se
retourner
ou ça vous paraît complètement hors de
portée ah ça ne paraît pas du tout hors
de portée je pense que d'abord il faut
bien comprendre ce que c'est que la
russie et l'ukraine se sont deux pays
qui ont une histoire commune
considérable depuis des siècles et des
siècles si vous lisez toute l'histoire
de ces deux pays vous voyez combien les
îles sont imbriqués à la fois par la
langue par la religion au passage le
débat sur le choc des civilisations dont
on a beaucoup parlé
je rappelle quand même que c'est un pays
blanc orthodoxe est en guerre avec un
d'autres pays blanc et orthodoxes donc
ça prouve bien que quelque part tout ça
mérite d'être remis dans une autre
perspective qui est une perte des lives
géopolitique donc nous ce que nous avons
par rapport à tout cela c'est évidemment
un objectif c'est de dire le mieux que
nous pouvons à la population russe
attention vous êtes votre dirigeant vous
souffre et partir sur une une direction
qui est absolument mais suicidaire car
il faut bien comprendre que les
conséquences de tout cela vont être
absolument dramatique pour l'ensemble du
monde pour cette partie du monde et bien
sûr pour la russie est même avancée des
conséquences pour la france et notamment
puisqu'on en plein salon de
l'agriculture et qu'on vous aide de
seine-et-marne qui est une région
évidemment fortement agricole des
conséquences emmanuel macron samedi a
parlé d'un plan de résilience est ce que
vous c'est la bonne solution car qui
doit contenir ce plan pour ça il faut
faire un peu attention parce que bien
sûr que nos secteurs économiques sont
très certains d'entre eux sont très
menacées bien sûr et puis le pouvoir
d'achat des français derrière donc on ne
voudrait pas de l'agriculture mais enfin
c'est aussi le secteur de l'énergie
c'est le secteur des composants c'est le
secteur de tout ce qui touche à des
centaines d'entreprises que les grands
groupes il ya aussi des centaines
d'entreprises billiers d'entreprise qui
commercent d'une manière ou d'une autre
avec eux avec la russie ou qui ont
besoin d'approvisionnements donc en fait
on est reparti il faut pas se raconter
des histoires on est reparti vers un
nouveau choc pour lequel il va falloir
trouver des réponses moi je mets juste
en gare de raisonnement public cclat
maintenant on est quand même un peu à la
à trouver le bon équilibre parce que
derrière tout ça il ya quand même une
campagne électorale on n'est dupe de
rien cette élection présidentielle
d'ailleurs il faut bien le dire 907
cette campagne présidentielle ne
ressemble plus à rien parce que tous et
tout est complètement faussé et bien
tenir encore elle
sanctionnée dans un état de droit mais
en revanche c'est tout l'enjeu de cette
campagne qui de ceux de ce résultat qui
est qu'il faut c'est parce que
on a un premier point qui est majeur aux
élections partielles ces deux tours
c'est que il faut absolument que la
finale le 1er tour le soir du premier
tour nous soyons entre deux candidats
dits de gouvernement de gens
responsables bon c'est à dire que si
on est avec une finale dans lequel on à
monsieur macron d'un côté monsieur
zemmour madame le pen de l'autre et bien
les jeux sont complètement faussé et
dans cette période on a besoin de gens
responsables pas de gens qui sont juste
là pour agiter les peurs sans aucune
solution concrète donc il est
indispensable que les français entendent
que le programme de gouvernement et de
réforme que propose valérie pécresse 2
mieux pour valérie pécresse a la
possibilité de les exposer et de le
faire de manière responsable nous nous
engageons pour cinq ans
au second tour sera résultats mais
complètement pourquoi avait tout
simplement parce que je n'imagine pas
une seconde que dans cette période de
deux 2 de conflits gravissime la france
les français puissent trouver quelques
raisons de porter monsieur zemmour ou
madame le pen à la tête du pays ou alors
c'est qu'on est on serait suicidaire
c'est le suicide française c'est le mot
de monsieur zemmour dans ce livre
totalement qui déconstruit l'histoire de
manière indigne notamment en évoquant
cette cette idée pétain aurait sauvé des
juifs pendant la guerre mais dire
combien temps en temps réel quand même
le l'extrémisme n'a pas de limites
pour ne pas employer d'autres termes on
voit bien qu'on est en réalité
aujourd'hui dans cette période de
campagne électorale dans un contexte
totalement fausse et il est donc capital
que valérie pécresse puisse recueillir
le suffrage des français pour être en
finale face à macro et ainsi avoir un
vrai débat de fond deuxièmement s'il
devait advenir que monsieur macron
soirée lui il sera réélu sur le seul
impact de la crise que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui est donc ça va complètement
fausses et l'interprétation du résultat
et le sens de ce éventuelle deuxième
qu'un client sans compter une possible
abstention très très forte parce qu un
contexte anxiogène comme celui ci est
peut-être de nature à détourner les gens
des urnes intérieur alors là pour ces
cas là je ne partage pas votre avis je
pense que cette période est une période
de très grande politisation au sens
noble du terme du débat au sens noble et
vous savez on a souvent pour habitude
moi j'ai les français les françaises
iront ils ont été massivement le 10
avril sait rien on verra bien mais moi
j'ai pris un peu de recul que moussa et
par rapport à la politique nationale qui
suivent moins présent dans le débat est
en tout cas plus présents dans
l'exercice de responsabilités depuis de
nombreuses années mais en même temps
j'essaie de faire partager l'expérience
qui est la mienne ce qui me frappe c'est
que piétine souvent les hommes
politiques ou pas sa vie allait fouler
aux pieds expliqué qu'ils sont nuls qui
savent rien faire sans compter et plein
de d'expliquer qu'ils sont malhonnêtes
enfin on a droit tout il ya un moment où
tout ce qui vient de donner des conseils
sont là à tourner leurs regards sur les
dirigeants politiques c'est le moment
des crises majeures crise
sociale crise économique où
naturellement crise diplomatique ou de
guerre comme celle là dans ces moments
là c'est la noblesse du pouvoir
politique que de prendre les bonnes
décisions et donc c'est un moment où il
faut que les français aillent voter
parce que c'est là que ça se passe les
laves là dans le moment précis que vous
êtes en train de décrire je vous ai le
sentiment que valérie pécresse s'affirme
comme comme on a une stature de chef 2
oui pour une raison que je vais vous
expliquer très simple on ne peut pas se
permettre dans des périodes comme celle
là d'avoir à la tête de notre pays des
gens dont le discours est un peu un
discours d' irresponsabilité à tous les
étages voilà le le le canton dans son
excuse et moore ou madame le pen je mets
de côté monsieur mélenchon dont les
propos ne laisse personne dupe mais je
sais que du côté de l'extrême droite
aujourd'hui il ya des français qui sont
séduits par certaines sirènes mais oui
ce qu'on voit là la très grande
faiblesse les arguments de madame le pen
ou de monsieur zemmour aujourd'hui la
manière dont on essaie de contourner le
problème j'ai pas dit ça mais je les dis
autrement
propos de la dîmière poutine ballon
livre pas les armes parce qu'on veut pas
être qu aux belligérants fin tout ça ça
montre en réalité que quand on est
populiste quand on est juste sur les
peurs d'une population mais qu'est ce
qu'on fait dans ces cas là bas on
raconte n'importe quoi pour agiter ses
peurs mais quand on est à la solution il
n'y a plus personne et ça c'est pour moi
capitale que dans ce contexte là valérie
pécresse qui a un vrai programme sur
tous ces sujets puisse opposer à
monsieur macron un projet alternatif
dans la sphère des partis de
gouvernement est ce que pour vous
françois bâillon bayrou a eu raison de
parrainer marine le pen permet d'être là
du tout moi je fais partie de ceux qui
ont trouvé absolument
inacceptable très très choquant cette
manière de faire une espèce de pseudo
campagne pour que les extrémistes et des
parrainages au motif que c'était le sens
de la démocratie il y as derrière cela
deux choses qui m'ont paru tout à fait
inacceptable première c'est que c'est
pas la vocation de monsieur bayrou de
faire ça voilà je lui dis il n'est pas
là pour encourager les extrémistes ou
alors faut arrêter de donner des leçons
de morale à tout le monde et puis
deuxièmement ébats deuxièmement parce
que je n'exclus pas qui est derrière ça
l'arrière pensée d'un calcul politique
pour aider monsieur macron alors si
c'est ça la strate la la grandeur de la
politique dont il nous parle depuis des
années eh ben je ne suis pas
du tout sur cette ligne voilà je le dis
d'autant plus que jean louis bourlanges
qui est quelqu'un pour lequel j'ai
beaucoup d'estimé si on n'est pas
d'accord sur tout a eu ces dernières se
créant même président louis thiès
proches de monsieur bayo a eu ces
dernières semaines des mots quand même
très clair pour rappeler les valeurs
notamment vis-à-vis de monsieur fillon
moi je pense que sur ces sujets il avait
raison mais enfin si c'est pour que son
chef de file parraine madame le pen
comment vous dire deux poids deux
mesures quand même un merci jean
françois copé merci beaucoup d'avoir
essayé notre invité ce matin
[Musique]